[Music]
you guys responded
and i heard you all it seems that you
enjoyed the top 10 satisfying moments
video that i rolled out not so long ago
so i think it's about time for volume 2.
we'll have another banger of a list
today so you better get ready but before
we get going i'd like to start off by
encouraging you to subscribe i still see
that a number of viewers aren't
subscribed to vinnie tube so if you are
one of those people
please click that subscribe button up
there so you can get updated with more
content like this next time i don't want
to keep you waiting anymore
so let's begin the show we start with
the moment when eins kills clementine
[Music]
there's not a lot to like about
clementine honestly speaking she's a
giggling psychopath out for blood and
she's racked up quite the body count in
the series
acts crazy and filled with bloodlust
she's also the type to adorn herself
with the armor of various adventurers
that have fallen victim to her
unfortunately though all that would come
to an end as she finds herself facing
off against irons she may be a seasoned
fighter who even got the jump on irons
at the start but all that is moot when
facing against such an overpowered force
like eins in the end
she finally meets her end in one of the
most excruciating moments the series has
to offer it's what they call a cruel and
unusual death but all in all
it does make sense considering the
characters involved judgment has come
for clementine
and it ain't pretty being slowly crushed
by the arms of irons is quite the brutal
way to go but after all she did i'd say
it's one of the most gratifying things
for the viewers to see her succumb to
her fate
i'd say that she earned every bit of it
no matter how brutal it may look
before we move on to the rest of the
list let me introduce today's sponsor
the walking dead survivors first off
what is the walking dead survivors
the walking dead survivors is the
official mobile game of the comic series
of the walking dead
elex takes us on an exhilarating and
interactive ride through the comic ip
the game story follows the comic
storyline and players get to play as
survivors in a bid to hold the fought
against hordes of invading zombies
your main goal is to build and fortify
your base in order to repel the incoming
zombie attackers besides buildings
you can also recruit people and
construct your ultimate army to create
the ultimate line of defense
beware though as zombies aren't the only
threat other players are as well so make
sure to head out and join the party as
early as possible
that one head start does matter if
you're interested in the walking dead
and want to find a way to relive the
comics don't forget to follow the
official social media for the game you
can get the latest
updates from the official youtube
twitter and instagram for the game
so head on down and check the video
links in the description while you're at
it why don't you also click the link to
download the walking dead survivors
doing so will provide you with an
invaluable head start against fellow
players and possible competition
download now and join the fun now back
to the video
time to praise the sun again because
eskenor's flex versus esterosa is next
on the list
eskino has had a lot of showcases of
power and for me one of my favorite of
these such moments came at the expense
of esterosa with the invasion of lioness
being well underway esterosa gets
singled out as the strongest of the ten
commandments it's a face-off between the
two strongest combatants in the two
fighting forces and guess what
it's a squash a blowout a stomp whatever
you want to call it granted esterosa
does get some offense in
seemingly devises a way to out eskenor's
source of power and gets his brief
moment of gloating however we all know
how the story ends in fights like this
especially going up against someone as
crazy as esknov escond just powers
through
everything and the moment his son breaks
through all the darkness that the enemy
can muster
it's all over an arrogant villain
getting his in such a decisive way
will never stop being satisfying
in one of the actions that can be
considered a bit more of a grey area
we have azkalad killing king sven hello
in one of the acts that helped establish
what a charismatic and interesting
character ascolat is he makes the
ultimate decision to murder king sven
it's quite a morally grey action and all
but as we all know this ain't just your
shonen fair
this is vinlan saga to be fair to ask
alad kingsville
isn't exactly a saint in fact what led
to the moment is his ultimatum to ask a
lad to pick between wales of prince knut
knowing asgalad's weakness the king
tried to use wales as a way to exploit
him but it ends up biting the king as he
gets
failed thanks to the wrong decision of
course this event then leads to a chain
of events that i could spend time
talking about in another video but for
now
this moment of decisive action ranks as
one of the most satisfying moments in
anime
next up is ash winning the pokemon
[Music]
[Applause]
league
[Applause]
would i be making a wrong bet to say
that a sizeable part of the audience
here wouldn't have been around when
pokemania took over the world that was
the late 90s and along with the massive
boom of pokemon came the anime's first
season and the main character never
changed
and he never won any pokemon league you
heard that right
for approximately two decades ash never
won a pokemon league
ever in all of those seasons of pokemon
at times the losses were clean but at
times it seemed that the writers just
pulled some random bs to keep him from
winning
the worst one in that season where the
writers just threw a random guy coming
out of nowhere packing legendaries at
him or his gray ninja losing despite
having type advantage
however all memes have to die someday so
ash finally won a pokemon league as the
sun and moon season came around
probably not the most decisive or hyped
win because pretty much everyone agrees
that he should have won the previous
season with his really cool grain ninja
but it's still there it's still
satisfying for 90s kids to see a part of
their childhood come to a close and
while the moment was a season too late
it still remains quite a cathartic
moment for some
[Music]
let's welcome helsing to the list now
with the saras and zorin blitz battle
zorin blitz didn't think too highly of
cyrus victoria even after the major's
warnings seres never became more than a
blip in zorin's radar however things
would take a big change once zorin
zeppelin got shot down and then it's
time
for the serious battle zorin in a surge
of sadism
manages to push seras as far as she
possibly can taking some of sarah's
body parts out of the picture isn't
enough and the revenge feels zorin
continues her assault culminating in the
killing of pip which proved to be the
breaking point
seras drinks his blood and unloads on
zorin finally awakening to her full
vampire powers
zorin is no match it's always satisfying
to see cocky's sadistic characters push
someone far enough
only to get destroyed in return it's a
common trope in anime but the sheer
graphicness of helsink makes this as one
of the moments that stand out in
particular
leech makes its return for volume two of
the list and we now take a look at the
alkiora fight
ichigo's decisive battle against or
kiyora took place somewhere towards the
end of the hueco mundo arc it's the
protagonist's last test before moving on
to the fake garagura town and beginning
the long confrontation with aizen then
he got destroyed hard holo mask and all
ichigo just isn't a match for okiora who
pretty much kills him by shooting
through his chest in front of orihime
however being on the brink of death just
seemed to bring out an inner beast in
ichigo and he comes back in a new hollow
form that just beats down all kia ora in
one of the most satisfying counter
squashes in bleach
paying a curb stomp back with another
one of his own in a chilling display
whether this sudden power-up was a good
decision writing-wise has been debated
for quite some time already however
as far as adrenaline hype and
satisfaction goes this moment
is just lit
we have a fake moment joining the list
now this time from unlimited blade works
among the mainline fake characters
few can match gilgamesh in terms of
haunting us and sheer arrogance for a
good reason you're looking at the king
of heroes arguably the most powerful
servant in the war
and owner of countless noble phantasms
just watch phase zero if he's still in
doubt of his power which makes it all
the more satisfying to see him being
brought down against not saber
a long-time rival from the previous war
by her new master
the humble and idealistic shiro yes it's
shiro who found a way to match the gate
of babylon best gilgamesh in close
combat and force him to unsheath aya so
much for the faker label her shiro
finally proves his worth as a hero and
protector
of justice who knew that the strongest
servant in the war would find his match
in a mere human being he's no legendary
hero
but the whole journey of rediscovery
that he went through in unlimited blade
works allowed shiro to get the prowess
and the will to defeat gilgamesh and
humble him down
[Music]
how about going back to a classic for
the next entry gohan going super saiyan
2 for the first time will always be a
part of my childhood and it's really a
goosebump raising moment of a good guy
finally having seen enough due to cell
killing android 16 and the cell juniors
running a mark against the z
fighters gohan finally breaks his limits
and taps into the next evolution of his
power becoming super saiyan 2. i don't
know what's more satisfying
the transformation sequence or the
destruction that he hands the cell
juniors right after the transformation
whatever it is
this will always be a moment the og
dragon ball fans would remember and
savor he then gets ready to face sale
himself and would end up being the one
to close the book on the saga with a
victory
eventually after months in real time yep
the meme about dragon ball fights being
almost an hour long is legit
[Music]
whitebeard silent rage earns him second
place on this list
rage comes in many forms personally i
feel that the silent fury type is the
one that evokes the strongest emotions
especially coming from someone as badass
as whitebeard it comes with a look that
makes you want to turn
tail and run as a kind who would soon
learn akainu might think of himself as a
hot shot but coming face to face with
whitebeard
the looming doom shown in the shot of
whitebeard towering over him just paints
an
excellent picture of how screwed he is
in that moment just check out whitebeard
simply tanking akainu's amazing looking
shot
and we can tell how far apart the two
are in terms of strength is this opening
punch one of the most satisfying punches
in anime history
some people certainly think so and if
you're one of those tell me on the
comment section below
just how badass could this man be
we finish off the list with the
legendary seven-page mother from
jojo golden win
one of the most satisfying moments in
golden wind comes in the form of
chocolate's demise
in his last pathetic attempt at
resistance he claims victory as he tries
to hold mr hostage
unfortunately the trap's been set and
the villain finds his brains blown out
with gold experiences ability
then comes the big one getting told by
giorno to know his place isn't
satisfying enough and it leads to this
golden
no pun intended there moment where
chocolata throws himself towards giorno
as a last resort however
it leads to gold experiences barrage
giorno
finishing off chocolate in one of the
most iconic scenes is
truly a sight to behold it's a complete
destruction that's been immortalized in
seven pages in the manga seeing the
barrage of attacks in anime form is just
super satisfying it takes a special
effort from the sound direction team to
give this scene justice but man
they did it
so how does this list look to you do you
think that is better than the first one
if you haven't watched that i'll be
leaving a link so you can go and check
it out yourself find your most
gratifying moment between the two lists
and share your thoughts on the comments
section
if you had fun with the content don't
forget to subscribe you might also want
to support the channel through two
avenues you can either become a member
or help me through patreon
don't forget to check out our sponsors
game the walking dead survivors
links in the description that'll be it
for this list i hope you enjoyed it and
i'll be seeing you next time
stay awesome everyone till next time
[Music]
[Applause]
you